THIS IS "THE FIVE"
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE SENATE PASSING A BILL TO
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT FOR THREE
WEEKS AND NOW HEADS TO THE HOUSE
FOR A VOTE EXPECTED TONIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCING A
DEAL TWO AND 35 DAY PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THE BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE WALL
FUNDING BUT THE PRESIDENT FAILS
TO KEEP FIGHTING FOR IT.
IT'S >> Mr. President: WALL
SHOULD NOT BE CONTROVERSIAL.
THAT IS WHY MOST OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS HAVE VOTED
IN THE PAST FOR BILLS THAT
INCLUDE WALLS AND PHYSICAL
BARRIERS AND VERY POWERFUL
SENSES.
IF WE DON'T GET A FAIR DEAL FROM
CONGRESS, THE GOVERNMENT WILL
EITHER SHUT DOWN OR ON
FEBRUARY 15TH, AGAIN, OR I WILL
USE THE POWERS AFFORDED TO ME
UNDER THE LAWS AND THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES TO ADDRESS THIS
EMERGENCY.
>> Dana: SENATE MINORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER PLACING A
SHUTDOWN CLAIM ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> HOPEFULLY NOW THE PRESIDENT
HAS LEARNED HIS LESSON.
WE CANNOT, CANNOT EVER HOLD
AMERICAN WORKERS HOSTAGE AGAIN.
WE HOPE TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
PRESIDENT, TO THE PUBLIC, THAT
THE PRESIDENT WAS IN CHARGE OF
THE SHUT DOWN.
>> Dana: HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI SAYING ONCE THE
GOVERNMENT BACK OPEN, SHE IS
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO SET A DATE FOR THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
SO, JESSE, BACK WHERE WE BEGAN
BEFORE THE SHUTDOWN EVEN
STARTED.
SO NOW, THREE WEEKS TO GO.
>> Jesse: YEAH, THANK GOD IT
IS OVER RIGHT NOW.
TRUMP LOST THE BATTLE SO WE HAVE
TO WIN THE WAR AND GET SOMETHING
OUT OF AN EMERGENCY DECLARATION
AND IF HE DOESN'T GET SOMETHING
DONE THEY ARE COMING HAS TO
FLOAT THEM ASKED WHAT THE
HELL'S.
>> Dana: DO YOU THINK HE WILL
DO NATIONAL EMERGENCY?
>> Jesse: I THINK TOO FAR
APART SO A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND HAS TO GET REELECTED SO MORE
OF A MANDATE, POLITICAL CAPITAL
TO GET THE WELL-FUNDED.
AT THIS POINT, THE LAST
SHUTDOWN, THE SCHUMER SHUTDOWN
AND THAT WAS PERFECTLY TEED UP
TO THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE SCHUMER
WAS PROTECTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OVER VETERANS GETTING
PAID.
THIS DYNAMIC WAS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
TOOK OWNERSHIP OF THE SHUTDOWN
AND THEN IT WAS THE BORDER WALL
FUNDING VERSUS AMERICAN FEDERAL
WORKERS GETTING PAID.
AND THAT REALLY WASN'T A VERY
GOOD DYNAMIC FOR HIM AND PELOSI
OBSTRUCTED THE MEDIA SO SHE JUST
WAITED HIM OUT.
FIVE WEEKS LATER AND PEOPLE
DIDN'T GET PAID AND THERE IS NO
BORDER WALL.
SO WHERE DO WE STAND?
I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE AIRPLANE
SITUATION, THE CALLOUS STATEMENT
FROM THE CONGRESS SECRETARY, THE
FBI DIRECTOR COMING OUT TO SAY
WE ARE REOPENING THIS THING TO
CRANK UP THE PRESSURE IN ORDER
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO CHANGE
GEARS.
>> Dana: SO SOMETIMES LEADERS
HAVE TO DO THAT, RIGHT, WELL,
THIS ISN'T WORKING AND WE HAVE
TO SWITCH GEARS.
>> Jesse: WHAT HE SAID.
WE LOST THE BATTLE BUT THERE
WERE STILL GOING, OKAY.
THIS IS TIRESOME, IT IS BORING
AND IT IS INFURIATING AND IT IS
FRUSTRATING BECAUSE THIS ISN'T
PURE POLITICS, THIS IS A
PETULANT REACTION TO A
PHENOMENON, RIGHT?
WALLS ARE NORMAL, WE HAVE WALLS
BUT WILLING TO SPEND MORE MINING
THEN ASKING FOR SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT IMMIGRATION AT ALL.
IT IS ABOUT TRUMP.
WHETHER YOU LIKE HIM OR HATE HIM
HE IS THE PHENOMENON FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS THAT CREATED THIS
ANIMOSITY.
THESE PEOPLE COME I DON'T SEE
ANY COMPROMISE COMING IN THIS
BECAUSE IF THE DEMOCRATS
COMPROMISE, THE MEDIA WILL JUST
RIP IT TO SHREDS.
THIS IS A PERSONAL VENDETTA
AGAINST TRUMP.
THEY ARE PUTTING NOW SECURITY
AND PUTTING THE GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, YOU KNOW TO THE SIDE
IN FAVOR OF THEIR OWN PERSONAL
TRUMP.
THAT IS WHY I FIND IT BORING AND
TIRESOME BECAUSE I KNOW THIS
ISN'T GOING TO CHANGE.
WE WILL GET TWO MORE YEARS,
POSSIBLY SIX MORE YEARS OF THIS.
>> Dana: AND I WANT TO ASK YOU
YOU, DAN WE ARE BACK WHERE WE
WERE BEFORE.
TO THE PRESIDENT'S SUPPORTERS
NOTE -- DO NOT DO FAVORS INTO
PUSHING HIM INTO FIGHTS HE
CANNOT WIN?
>> Dan: NO BECAUSE HE CAN WIN
THIS.
I THOUGHT SCHUMER HANDLE THAT
AWFULLY.
NANCY PELOSI CLEARLY UNDERSTOOD
SHE HAD TO TOW THE METAL WHILE
GIVING THE PRESS CONFERENCE.
SCHUMER CAME UP LIKE A TOTAL
SNAKE.
TRUMP CAPITULATES THE GOVERNMENT
AND WHAT THE SCHUMER DUKE, HE
COMES OUT IN TWICE REPEATS THE
POINT, YOU LEARNED A LESSON.
THERE WAS NO NEED FOR THAT.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T NEED TO BE
A SORE LOSER.
SPEED EIGHT HE SHOULD PULL THAT
DEAL OFF OF THE TABLE, AND THE
SECOND POINT, POLITICS IS ABOUTA
SECOND POINT, POLITICS IS ABOUTD
SECOND POINT, POLITICS IS ABOUTI
DON'T MEAN MONEY FOR BUILDING A
POLITICAL CAPITAL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THREE WEEKS TO
RACE TO THE FINISH LINE TO GET A
DEAL HIS BASE CAN REALLY CALL.
IT WAS NOT A GREAT DAY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: BUT IF HE DOESN'T DO
THAT AND A NATIONAL EMERGENCY,
DO YOU THINK THE BASE WOULD BE
FINE WITH THAT?
>> Dan: I'M NOT A HUGE FAN BUT
CENTRALIZING POWER IN GOVERNMENT
EVEN AN OFFICE AS A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT AND I USED TO BE A
HYPOCRITE ON THAT BUT HAVING
SAID THAT, THE CONGRESS DID
DELEGATE POWER BUT I DON'T AGREE
WITH IT BUT IT IS THEY ARE.
>> Dana: IT IS AN OPTION.
>> Dan: AND IT MAY BE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT BUILDING
THE WALL BY THE WAY IT MAKES IT
THROUGH THE COURTS FROM A BOAT
LOAD OF ALL BEFORE HE GETS IT.
>> Dana: AND COMPLETED BY THEN
THEN.
MARIE, THE PRESIDENT SAID WE
DON'T NEED 2,000 MILES OF A
CONCRETE WALL.
I'VE ALREADY SAID THAT, AND
VOTED FOR BARRIERS, SO WHAT ARE
WE FIGHTING OVER AT THIS POINT?
>> Marie: I THINK DONALD TRUMP
OR POLITICAL TEAMS SO WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE SENATE YESTERDAY
THAT MITCH McCONNELL WAS VERY
SHREWD IN SETTING FORWARD BOTH
BILLS TO SHOW DEMONSTRATING TO
THE PRESIDENT THAT HIS PLAN HAD
FEWER VOTES, ACTUALLY, AND
EVENTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED.
A CR TO FIGHT OVER THIS A FEW
MORE WEEKS.
THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY AT THIS
TIME THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING WE
WILL DO ACR FOR THREE WEEKS FOR
A VERY LARGE DOWN PAYMENT.
THE PRESIDENT AGREED TO DO THAT
WITH NO DOWN PAYMENT AND SO I
THINK HE SAW THE POLITICAL
WRITING FOR THE OVAL OFFICE TO
ADDRESS AND ALL THE WAY HE'S
BEEN MESSAGING.
THE NUMBERS HAVE NOT MOVED AND
HE'S GETTING BLAMED.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT GIVEN THE
FACT THE DEMOCRATS FEEL LIKE
THEY WON THIS ROUND, EMPOWERED
TO MAKE A COMPROMISE.
SOMETHING LIKE I SAID YESTERDAY,
LET'S SAY $5 BILLION THAT
INCLUDES BARRIERS WHERE EXPERTS
THEY NEEDED AND THE PRESIDENT
TODAY TALKING ABOUT EXPERTS.
I LIKE THAT TOO, A COMMISSION --
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A SCOTT
ADAMS IDEA.
>> Dan: BUT I THINK THE
DEMOCRATS MAY FEEL EMPOWERED TO
SAY, OKAY, NOW, WE ARE GOING TO
COMPROMISE ON THIS IF WE GET
DACA, GPS.
I THINK THE OTHER LESSON FROM
THIS, NANCY PELOSI IS SOMEONE I
HAVE UNDERESTIMATED AS A
DEMOCRAT.
I WANTED SOMEBODY ELSE TO BE
SPEAKER.
I UNDERESTIMATED HER ABILITY TO
WIN THE ROLL BACK IN HER
UNDERESTIMATED HER TO GO TOE TO
TOE-TO-TOE WITH TRUMP.
THINGS ARE GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
NOW.
SHE SHOWED STRENGTH.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE BOTH
WORKHORSES AND SIMILAR IN AGE.
RIGHT?
SHE'S BEEN AROUND, HE'S BEEN
AROUND, BUT WHAT ARE THEY
FIGHTING FOR?
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS, THE UGLY IN
A DIVORCE.
THE UGLY FACE IN A DIVORCE.
WHEN MARRIED, IMMIGRATION NOBODY
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT.
AND THEN THEY GET IN A FIGHT AND
FIGHTING OVER, THEY DON'T EVEN
LIKE THE VASE BUT THEY WILL
FIGHT OVER IT EVEN THOUGH IT'S
NOT A BIG DEAL.
TO THE POINT YOU BROUGHT UP
ABOUT THE PANEL OF EXPERTS AND
ENGINEERS, ON THIS GROUP, IT'S A
STEP FORWARD WHICH MEANS FOR THE
WAR, HE COULD WIN THIS USING
THAT.